I was wondering what you saw with Santa Clause,
if it's a healthy thing for parents to practice,
what's the psychological impact of lying to your child?
Look,
I think the,
I think lying is the wrong way of thinking about this.
Santa Claus is a game.
It's a game of pretend and children play games of pretend all the time,
you know,
so I don't see any harm in that at all.
Now,
you know,
you don't want to prolong that belief beyond its natural end point.
But it's a,
it's a massive game and it's a lovely game and I don't believe that there's
anything harmful in it in the least.
So now what's the psychological impact of lying to your child?
Let's we can think about that more generally.
Don't lie to your children.
Don't lie.
Period.
Lying is a really bad idea.
It's a really bad idea.
Um,
it never works.
You might think it works,
but that's only because you're blind to the consequences and probably willfully
blind.
Plus it's a terrible weight.
You know,
if you,
if you don't lie,
there's a lot fewer things to keep track of.
Your life is a lot more pristine and crystally and,
and then things that you,
that come your way maybe you deserve in some small measure.
And it's a bad idea to lie now,
but I don't think it's a bad idea to play pretend games with your children.
I think that's okay.